well what is that it's harder to publish
fiction of any kind so it would be
interesting to compare those figures
with the figures for first novels for
instance or first collections of short
stories it may be that just as many are
being published but fewer people are
being published by major publishers so
in general there's a contraction of
literary publishing that's been going on
since the contraction of independent
bookstores the mergers of many small
publishers into larger corporations so
there are now really far fewer major
players in the publishing world and
there were even when I started 20 years
ago and I think the the fundamental
change of attitude is when publishers
started to look at each book as needing
to carry its own weight financially so
whereas in the Golden Age of American
publishing publishers many of them were
well-off and we're not looking to make
any money to begin with this but for
those who were in the business of
profit-making they knew that only a few
titles were really going to turn a
profit and they expected that those few
bestsellers would carry the more noble
part of publishing the serious
literature that might not make any money
but presumably as more NBA started to
come into the workings of publishers and
publishers became more corporate we now
believe that every book needs to carry
its own weight it needs to carry a an
equivalent share of the overhead cost as
a big bestseller so two per copy that
book needs to contribute as much to
salaries and health insurance and lights
as as a big bestseller which really
makes it
harder to publish books that might only
sell a few thousand copies and almost
all translation falls into that category
and has the additional impediments of
the additional cost for the translation
and the fact that is much harder to
promote authors so in this period as
well as become essential that authors
promote themselves it's very hard for
foreign language author coming into this
market with no no experience with
American entrepreneurship and market and
self-marketing
to be able to do that even if they speak
English and of course most of them are
writing in their foreign language
because they are that is the language
they're comfortable and they're not
comfortable writing or speaking and
speaking in English some can speak in
English but in such a way that with with
enough of an accent that radio programs
might not want interview them you might
not wanna interview them the so that the
foreignness becomes a handicap in the
promotion more than in the actual work
the wonderful thing about publishing is
that there is so much serendipity so
there's no one path to publication in
some cases authors are living in the
States because they have a teaching job
at a university or they are journalists
based in the United States for a period
and they form connections that make it
easier for them to get published in
English in other cases they would a
Nobel Prize and suddenly publishers are
scrambling for the rights to works that
they had previously completely ignored
what what words on our borders has tried
to do is provide the kind of routes
publication that small magazines have
served for english-language authors or
even big magazines so for instance if it
English language fiction writers has a
story published in The New Yorker and
nobody's ever heard of that writer
before suddenly there's a rush to
publish works by that author other
english-language writers have gotten
known through the Paris Review or Granta
or any number of well-regarded
Quarterly's there has been really no
such thing for writers in translation
because the small journalists usually
didn't have people who could read
foreign languages or didn't have a large
enough and that of connections among
translators some journals have done some
but words of the borders is really the
only one to my knowledge that focuses
exclusively on literature and
translation and has really put all of
its energy and seeking new work into
building a network of translators
foreign publishers and other reliable
allies to recommend work for translation
and publication
the best translations are done by people
who are also writers and it's much more
common in Europe for example for
literary writers to also try their hand
at translation in some cases actually to
make a living at translation to support
their their their own artistic work now
in this country there's just no
opportunity to make a living doing
translations so and writers are just
much much less likely to study foreign
languages and to really have a foot in
another language as I sought to say
there aren't any but it's just much less
common so it's hard to find it is hard
to find a good translators there's a lot
of academic translation which i think is
not as strong where the where an
academic is coming to something from a
particular ideological point of view or
a sense of the nonfiction interest of
the work but perhaps a less strong sense
of the texture of the language as a as a
poetic or literary endeavor so that said
we have a fantastic network of
translators and it's been built up now
over ten years and the editorial
director of words Without Borders Susan
Harris has also been one of the lead
players in the American literary
translators Association and I think we
have the best nap Network out there
it's much harder for a foreign language
author to get an American agent and
again American editors and American
agents like American editors are less
likely to read foreign languages the
exceptions like George Borchardt have
been hugely important to American
literary culture George Borchardt
arrived in this country fluent in in
French and was the agent for Beckett and
ionesco and Jean Shanae and there was a
whole generation of people who really
refugees from Nazi Germany and from
nazi-occupied Europe and during the
Second World War who ended up here held
in Kurt Wolff or another example and
they were hugely important to bringing
European literature into English